It's morning again in America
Today more women will go to work than ever before in our country's history
This year dozens of children will be born to happy and healthy families. It's morning again
It's morning again
Wake up America mornings over
I was asleep before that's how we let it happen
When they slaughtered Congress we didn't wake up
When they blamed terrorists and suspended the Constitution
We didn't wake up then either
Now I'm awake you girls will serve the leaders and their barren wifes
You will bear children for them
There is an eye in your house
I want to keep on living for her
Do not let them grind you down. You fight!
They should have never given us uniforms if they didn't want us to be an army